Emily couldn't wait to get her math test back.
She had studied hard and knew she had done well.
Mrs. Meed handed back all the tests, but Emily didn't get her test.
Joe didn't get his either.
"I have two tests without names," Mrs. Meed said.
"Do you know which test is yours?"
Mrs. Meed asked Emily and Joe.
Emily and Joe looked at the papers.
One had one mistake, but the other had fifteen mistakes.
Emily reached for the paper with one mistake.
"This one is mine," she said.
Joe said, "No, I think it's mine."
"It looks like my writing," Emily said.
"It looks like mine, too," Joe said.
Emily stomped her foot and said, "I know it's mine!"
"Your name isn't on it," Joe said.
"Neither is yours," Emily said back.
"There's only one thing to do since you can't decide," Mrs. Meed said.
"What's that?" Emily and Joe asked.
"You'll both have to take the test again," Mrs. Meed said.
Emily and Joe groaned.
"This time, please follow all the directions," Mrs. Meed said.
"First, write your name on your paper.
Then answer the questions.
When you're finished, bring me your test."
Emily thought the test was easy.
She didn't miss any questions.
Joe thought it was hard.
He missed twelve questions.
Emily said, "Next time, I'll put my name on my paper."
And Joe said, "Next time, I'll study for the test."
"I could help you study," Emily offered.
"Would you?" Joe asked.
"Then maybe I'll do as well as you."